ragazzi ho scaricato il gioco di oggi
che sembra un horror con i contro maroni
dico solo che in partenza la cartella e
quest'anno la pro icona del gioco e
questa va bene come tutti ho ma con lo
slider man ma dai
cosa c'entra lo slider mai visto gioco
in materia
dato questo lo slider man this land and
round il mio primo video su youtube
giuro su dio la juve nascondere sotto le
crocchette quella l'usl intermedi del
mio del primo video che fece su youtube
io sono una nana arrivo a malapena alla
maniglia va bene permesso quella è la
casa this land era un tre ragazzi ma
cos'è mai fatto dagli stessi creatori
this land and round che veramente il
primo video che fece su youtube chance
al contrario salve a quelli ci sono
delle robe qua è però allegro allegro
comunque come tutti i giochi che si
rispettano ci alziamo ci troviamo in un
posto senza sapere dove mese come ci
siamo arrivati
chiaramente ovvio perché madonna quanto
ho fatto bene sto gioco però bellissimo
la smettiamo di mettere i quadri philos
lander man
tutta napoli ma laddove arrivata ma non
è che se non lo capiva bene ho capito ma
se come ma non ho neanche visto cosa è
successo
aridaje ma non ha neanche visto cosa è
ho sentito e sentivo dei bassi diciamo
che vabbè primo jump schiera caso ok
pagava state car come ho fatto prima non
sa non beccarla subito la zia quando mi
avvicino cosa è successo
cosa mi aspettavo che ho detto ma dai
quello non è un menù fisso quello non è
un menù fisso quello non ferma il gioco
ok ok cosa è successo bardini partiti
partiamo comunque menù fisso e quello
che avete al sushi questo volevo
intendere il menu quello che blocca il
gioco ok non si era bloccato il gioco
ottimo il menù non serva una sega il
menu conti il gioco continua ad andare
ottimo
no perché sai che perché va guardato
andata via quindi credibile cesana roba
incredibile sta innanzi tutto sotto il
tavolino quindi ottima cosa posso fare
un metro senza che mi ammazzino ti prego
porca vacca porca porca porta a porta
manca porca a sono sotto il tavolo so
che ti becca ragazzi sto facendo un
metro fatto da quando di un metro nelle
digit forse si spengo la torcia storici
posso uscire dalla finestra
a quanto pare la torcia poi anche non
spegnere è un gioco brutto qualcuno mi
spiega dove dovrei andare che un'ora e
mezza che gioco e di sottodiciotto
quindi modo di qua
porca vacca porque porque è
difficilissimo cosa devo fare
mariga non ho capito cosa dovrei come
faccio come faccio davanzali sto gioco
ve lo giuro non so non capisco io non
capisco frate non stai ma posso lasciare
questo lasciare questo è certo
poi quello che non esistono i check
point
non è che dice ci sono i check point
quindi puoi salvare gli imputo salvi per
questo non sto capendo cosa devo fare
proprio non c'è modo di fare niente non
puoi fare niente
vabbè ma stesso sopra i mobili non ha
preso via via via ma errata di qua a
luca ciao zia 6 aprile i mobili ma non
sai salire sulle credenze non aver avuto
un'infanzia visto io come sa divisione
credenze io c'è una porta sul soffitto
che è una porta e bassa dove vai
vorresti uccidermi e scarsa come la
morte sei tra andata molto bene ai a
ternate stata al tavolo riesco a fare
più di un metro in questo gioco comunque
ottimo sono già mi inquieta basta vai a
casa tua
non sempre aperte che somiglia un po
michael jackson se corro come un puledro
da adesso vai sto correndo sono più
veloce io sono più veloce io sono andato
18 no aiuto non si sa di qua sopra
non ci salì a non sei scarsa fai schifo
vai via no ragazzi dovete datemi insomma
come si salva salma sarà la partita
per l'amor di dio dove non avendo o non
avendo la sento ma non la vedo sono
sopra uno scaffale
come fate ad arrivare fino qua no
ragazzi aiuto salviamola parte salva la
partita save game save the game
per cortesia che un qualcosa che dovrei
fare per proseguire in questo gioco
eccola la zia lo sapessi di fare sorella
fai schifo vai via lo vedi che fai
schifo se riesco a salire su tutte le
cose di là non c'è niente perché ho
visto sono arrivato lì non c'erano al
massimo c'è qualcosa sotto le scale
ragazzi all in mezzo o sotto le scale
perché da altre parti non c'è ne vai via
vai a vai via
ma non c'è qualcosa anche qua c'è una
scala che porta di sopra sopra dove dove
che porta scalate a non so se andare
sotto la scala giu
qua in mezzo non dovrebbe esserci null
abili la scala scarterei o sotto la
scala gioco qua a destra sotto la scala
giù dai
mi sono rotto una gamba perché sono
sceso dallo scaffale
io voglio morire voglio morire come ho
fatto
dai dai almeno fa mi ripartire da lì da
ragazzi che fastidio pigliaru bulgaro io
non so veramente che cosa dire ma come
ho fatto a morire
senti qua ma dai si poteva essergli qua
non lo sapevo
no non ci sei anche di qua o là ma non
puoi essere ovunque mai c'era anche
dellal possa mandare veramente capirla
allora scusa eh va beh allora faccio
arrivare gli da una parte e poi vado
dall'altra apre a rivedere di qua se
riesco a fare qualcosa di decente visto
che fino a questo punto ci arrivò il che
è ottimo
ok quindi adesso è venuta di qua e non
posso più di superare subire damon io
devo farlo arrivare da una parte poi
andare dall'altra per forza è l'unica è
l'unica sono l'esca scendere sempre che
voi non si teletrasporta dall'altra
parte però eccole qua
ma porca [ __ ] sono completamente
immobile ci avrebbe da serie non mi
muovo non faccio passi non si sente
niente di quello che sto facendo
questo è l'unico modo per non farla
arrivare qua prima che e dall'altra
parte della stanza quindi dove sto
andando cioè lei comunque mi sono un
pazzo maniaco a prescindere come la
chiamiamo tra l'altro mafalda mafalda
mafalda ma però la porta e mi sento non
ha sentito
no non mi puoi raggiungere mai qua mai
ok se n'è andata non ho fatto un giro
strano e sta tornando
sta facendo dei giri particolari ok vedi
che ci sono delle scale che portano c6
dove sono caduto di sotto
c'è un telo nero dai ci sono i cadaveri
i cadaveri tutto a posto i cadaveri il
suo gioco fa niente non mi ha visto non
mi ha visto mio dio sono cascato des 8
quell'asta sulla scala ma sono dietro
tivano non mi può arrivò a giungere mai
qua solo dietro al divano
c'è qualcosa di più tranquilla non vi
piace qualcosa lo vedete che cosa che
lampeggia nazione come ha fatto come ha
fatto
ma come ha fatto ma come ho fatto ero
fermo ero fermo e lo fai un guardato
dylan è stato il gioco più strano della
mia vita
il loro gioco svenderà ultimi sacher a
loro perché hanno gli dei poster risl
entrambe è stato il primo gioco portato
sul canale mini sono contento di aver
fatto un video sul gioco della stessa
casa di produzione che ha fatto il primo
gioco dovranno sul canale marcava
carmelo detta bene come vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi spiega che hai lasciato un bel
mi piace la campanellina che ci sta lì
sotto ha spettatori e se cliccata del
vostro bel mouse o di chi lo sa che ci
sono baci ragazzi è importante e ci
vediamo come sempre a un prossimo video
belle ragazze
[Musica]